[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
le rythme dans la peau
ces élèves perfectionnent leurs
chorégraphies à peine âgée de 8 ans est
déjà en plein apprentissage du hip hop
tu peux m'expliquer ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui par la danse les
échauffements et les abonnements
j'aimais bien danser
et c'est ma copine sina m'avait donné
envie d'essayer une envie venus par le
bouche à oreille mais si le hip hop est
aujourd'hui considérée comme une danse
comme les autres elle n'a pas toujours
profité d'une bonne réputation
filles nées dans les années 70 dans le
bronx quartier connu de new york pour
ces gangs et ses trafics de drogue
la culture hip hop se développe dans les
années 80 90 des artistes comme haïti ou
ndbl des favoris son ouverture mais
véhicule une image violente
[Musique]
professeur depuis 15 ans au sein de
l'association illicites dance
adeline a noté une véritable évolution
dans les mentalités
je pense qu'il ya eu un phénomène de
mode aussi je pense que les émissions
aussi comme les star académie ce genre
de choses qui ont ouvert la danse tout
simplement la danse au terme large
les gens ont découvert un petit peu plus
la danse et le hip hop qui était quand
même un milieu très fermé à l'époque
très sains de rue
c'était vraiment une danse de rue qui
aujourd'hui est devenu vraiment un style
très moderne c'est la danse actuelle du
moment cet engouement favorise aussi la
diversité culturelle
malgré l'aspect agressif souvent mise en
avant le mouvement hip hop se veut une
culture de respect et de mixité sociale
vous avez vu les les les petites têtes
de denges que j'ai dans mon cours qui
viennent faire du hip hop
donc ça c'est juste génial en fait c'est
plus c'est plus réservé 1
à
à une tranche sociale en fait c'est plus
à l'époque comme on disait c'est ce
qu'est pas trop les moyens qui faisait
ça un peu tout seul de leur côté
aujourd'hui non c'est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde
un style que chacun peut pratiquer à une
seule condition c'est un conseil pour
être bon il comptait pour connaître les
pas pour est très sûr la musique pour
tous
[Musique]